jedediah mila from fox news was just
brought on to the view so she was from a
sort of center-right news outlet was
brought onto this left-wing news outlet
and she was just there to plug her book
but she was asked about kovid they
wouldn't let her go into the studio
because she refused to take the
fouchyache they made a big deal about
this and then they railroaded her
because she was stating perfectly true
things
about the virus
let's address the elephant in the room
because you were supposed to join you
were supposed to join us in the studios
weeks ago but you couldn't because abc
has a very strict policy uh you can't
get into this building unless you're
fully vaccinated everybody in this room
knows that and is vaccinated but you are
made a conscious decision not to get the
vaccine i have a medical exemption to
the vaccine that's been written by my
infectious disease vaccinated specialist
in new york city that's been co-signed
by three other doctors i'm not a
candidate for this vaccine i also have
sky high
multi-tiered multi-faceted natural
immunity very very high that has also
been proven it has been shown and it is
substantiated by letters from these
doctors so for me personally this
vaccine poses a greater risk than a
benefit but the vaccine does not prevent
you from getting covered and does not
prevent you from transmitting oh my
goodness
yeah that's not so come on no you've
been at foxton
i just don't understand why you would
choose to prioritize your personal
freedom over health and safety of others
and i just i just i just really don't
think that we should allow this kind of
misinformation um again
so jenna dylan jedi is obviously right
and the cackling hands over the viewer
are
not just rude and not just
unprofessional
i suppose their professional job
actually is to shut up conservatives so
there you go i guess they're being very
professional but but they're also wrong
here
they're also just what jedediah said is
absolutely true the cdc admits that
about transmission of the virus and
contracting the virus even after the
vaccine the cdc admits that
so
what what they're saying what she's
saying is absolutely right then what
cackling hen number two i don't know her
name on the view said over there is i
don't know why you're
why you're prioritizing your personal
freedom over my safety jedi is not what
she said was she's prioritizing her
safety over perhaps your safety although
the point she's making also is that the
vaccinated people can still transmit the
virus as the cdc acknowledged at the end
of july
which was their argument for why
vaccinated people still need to wear the
masks and socially distance and all that
other nonsense
so it's not it's not even a battle
between my freedom and
our safety it's it's a contest between
my safety and
oh and that's it and no one else's
safety because the
threat to other people's safety is not
really going to change
and if the vaccine is so effective at
preventing you the recipient from from
hospitalization and death then you don't
need to worry about what someone else is
doing necessarily
but then they cut off her mic
they cut off from mike they say you've
been at fox news too long or you've been
you're too conservative or something
the woman is
reciting lines from the cdc from the
scientists from the public health
experts
but
they contradict the left's political
narrative and so they're going to cut it
off and i think the crucial thing about
this clip
is when they cut her mic off
when she brings those facts when she
brings that science
they cut it off and they can cut it off
and yes you know you talk about fox news
it's kind of a center-right news outlet
there are some
conservative outlets out there on
alternative media obviously we're a very
large platform here at the daily wire
but the left
for the left it's not just a handful
like we have on the right it's abc nbc
cbs new york times this that the other
thing
it's the whole it go it's the whole blob
and so
they can cut you off and for most people
you're just going to hear the cackling
hands and you're not going to hear the
science i'm glad you liked that clip
subscribe
please please that would be great ring
the bell you will get the notifications
if you really want to guarantee you get
the notifications in the whole
uncensored show head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts that's the place to get it type
in the michael knowles show leave a
five-star review if you wouldn't mind
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you